merci d'être avec nous aujourd'hui merci
de votre invitation ce livre c'est quand
même énorme c'est mille pages ça vous a
pris quatre ans de travail qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé personnellement à piloter
cette ouvrage sur la violence faite aux
femmes il y a plusieurs événements
d'abord dans l'histoire française par
exemple dans l'actualité française qui
m'ont considérablement choqué
en particulier au début des années 2000
nous avons eu deux affaires très
différentes mais qui ont toutes les deux
conduites à la mort de deux femmes la
première c'est le terrible meurtre de
Soan Benziane donc une jeune femme
d'origine maghrébine qui a été retrouvé
gravement brûlé dans une cave dans une
cité à Vitry-sur-Seine
et puis de l'autre bien sûr le meurtre
de Marie Trintignant donc ces deux
affaires
en gros
ont une chronologie assez similaire
puisque soit une benzian c'est 2002
Marie Trintignant C 2003 et puis ces
femmes en fait se retrouvent dans un
dans un spectre socio-économique
extrêmement élargi parce que on a une
jeune femme
issue de l'immigration qui vit dans un
quartier populaire et puis on a bien sûr
une femme qui est une grande comédienne
qui appartient à une grande famille du
cinéma français et puis je fais le
constat que finalement ça peut toucher
Marie Trintignant et bien on meurt
d'une manière extrêmement brutale et
bien sûr violente
[Musique]
et donc ça ça produit un électrochoc en
fait et ça s'ajoute à plein d'autres
choses
que je voyais dans l'actualité que je
recevais en lisant des travaux de
chercheuses en particulier bien sûr ce
qui se passe à partir des années 90 au
Mexique où va naître d'ailleurs le
concept de féminicide au Mexique ça crée
une de masse c'est oui alors c'est là
que le féminicide est défini pour la
première fois parce que en fait on se
retrouve confrontés sur la zone
frontalière entre les États-Unis et le
Mexique donc la zone qui est
peuplée de machinesadoras donc les
usines de sous-traitance ou travail pour
l'essentiel des jeunes femmes à des
jeunes femmes pauvres et puis parfois
aussi des jeunes femmes natives et dans
ce contexte là qui est un contexte
socio-économique extrêmement difficile
on commence en fait à voir
des femmes disparaître de manière très
récurrente au départ les faits sont
isolés donc personne ne constate un
problème mais au fur et à mesure les
familles commencent à trouver que ça
fait beaucoup bien sûr de disparu et
elles exigent des réponses de la police
en particulier qui est évidemment non
fournit aucune ce qui fait qu'elle
commence des investigations et au cours
de ces investigations et bien elle
découvre des cadavres dans les lieux
isolés dans des décharges on s'en est
débarrassé comme des déchets ou même
dans des fosses communes et lorsqu'on
ouvre ses fausses communes et qu'on
exume les corps on découvre que les
femmes n'ont pas été seulement tuées
mais sur tuer donc elles ont subi toute
une série de violences près ou post
mortem qui vont en gros du viol ou des
membres man à la mutilation sexuelle etc
et donc face à cette situation
totalement folle parce que c'est pas dit
femme sans femme mais ça ça devient vite
des milliers de femmes qu'on
comptabilise et bien une grande
chercheuse mexicaine qui s'appelle
Marcela Lagarde de l'os Rios décide
d'inventer un nouveau concept de forger
un nouveau mot pour rendre finalement
intelligible ce non sens absolu qui est
ce crime de masse donc que vivent bien
sûr en majorité les Mexicaines le terme
féminicide
[Musique]
pour qui écrire ce livre mon idée
c'était de produire un livre contre le
déni parce que à chaque fois en fait
qu'on met en avant ou très souvent quand
on met en avant les questions des
violences systémiques contre les femmes
on nous répond pas du tout c'est pas du
tout un système ses conjoncturel
c'est trop général de dire ça
probablement vous êtes un peu hystérique
ce qui va en général avec et puis il y a
une délégitimation assez générale de la
pensée et du discours des chercheus
féministes les chiffres sont effrayants
parlons-en 47000 femmes tuées en 2020
par un conjoint ou par un membre de leur
famille
selon l'ONU c'est énorme quoi
c'est énorme et c'est minoré parce qu'en
réalité on sait que dans tous nos pays
d'abord on compte pas de la même manière
on compte pas les mêmes femmes donc il y
a des comptages restrictifs par exemple
en France on va compter seulement les
féminicides par partenaire intime on va
pas compter les féministes par un membre
de la parenté masculine on va pas
compter les meurtres de femmes parce que
ce sont des travailleuses du sexe parce
que ce sont des meurtres lesbophobes
transphobes ou parce que par exemple ont
une femme native donc on a des comptages
différents déjà dans de très nombreux
pays en fait on compte de manière très
réductionniste pourquoi est-ce autant de
violence envers les femmes et vous dites
même dans ce livre que la chasse aux
sorcières ça existe encore absolument ça
existe dans de très nombreux endroits du
monde au moment où nous parlons ça
existe par exemple
en Inde ça existe en Papouasie Nouvelle
Guinée ça existe au Ghana ça existe en
Arabie Saoudite et qu'est-ce qu'on leur
fait à ces fins la même chose ce sont
des meurtres de voisinage à chaque fois
qu'il y a une situation de crise
inexpliquée un enfant qui meurt une
épidémie qui arrive une récolte qui est
brûlée etc il faut trouver un bouc
émissaire et comme par hasard le bouc
émissaire bah c'est souvent une femme
tout ça ça remonte en fait à une très
ancienne haine des femmes les féministes
des années 70 ont défini d'abord le
fémicide comme un crime de haine premier
point et comme un crime de propriétaire
deuxième point c'est à dire crime de
propriétaire nous nous avons le Code
civil napoléonien qui est quand même
l'un des plus grands monuments de
misogynie mondiale un promulgué en 1804
et dans son article 213 que dit le Code
civil français il dit la femme doit
obéissance à son mari premier pas et
deuxième point dans le même code civil
il est indiqué extrêmement clairement
que la femme est la propriété de l'homme
ça a été abrogé je parle là du début du
19e siècle mais on voit bien que si
c'est traduit dans la loi ça veut dire
que dans les mentalités déjà c'est
installé et que on retrouve ça encore
aujourd'hui dans dans les féminicits
très contemporains parce que lorsqu'on
écoute les criminels dans les cours
d'assises par exemple souvent leur
justification c'est c'est ma chose c'est
ma femme c'est ma chose elle
m'appartient elle n'avait absolument pas
le droit de me quitter de m'enlever mes
enfants tous ces possessifs traduit bien
en fait le fait que il y a
précisément un crime de propriétaire
si on prend par exemple un attentat
masculiniste très important dans
l'histoire du Québec contemporain donc
l'attentat contre l'École Polytechnique
de Montréal et lorsqu'on voit la lettre
que laisse marque le pin après avoir
exécuté parce qu'il s'agit d'une
exécution 14 jeunes filles et d'en avoir
blessé très autres sans parler de celles
qui se sont suicidées après etc et bien
il annonce clairement la couleur il dit
clairement qu'il s'agit d'une réparation
contre c'est je cite [ __ ] de féministe
qui lui ont rendu la vie impossible
et ça c'est un crime de haine et il le
dit de manière extrêmement puissante et
Claire un tel choc au Québec ça a pris
du temps avant qu'on puisse
accepter cette réalité là absolument
mais parce que ça ça ça
met à mal la mythologie de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes dans nos
sociétés évidemment on a quand même
avancé il s'agit pas de dire que il ne
sait rien passé vous parlez aussi dans
ce livre de ce qui se passe dans une
grande partie du monde en Chine en Inde
toutes ces petites filles manquantes 200
millions de petites filles manquantes
quand tu avant la naissance ou juste
après aujourd'hui on est il y a 899
filles qui naissent pour 1000 garçons et
que malgré toutes les lois qui ont été
mis en place en Inde pour stopper le
processus en l'occurrence le processus
s'accroît et donc qu'on pourrait arriver
à l'échéance de 2030 à avoir 200 filles
manquantes par par milliers de garçons
donc avec des conséquences encore
terribles aussi pour les femmes alors
avec les chercher ailleurs épouvantable
parce que la rareté des femmes ne
privilégie pas d'une certaine manière ça
ne rend pas leur situation meilleure ça
accentue les mariages précoces les
mariages forcés ça accentue la
polyandrie forcée c'est à dire que dans
certaines parties d'Inde où il y a
presque plus de femmes en âge de travail
de procréer de se marier ou de procréer
et bien on va dans une fratrie dans une
famille achetée pour l'ensemble de la
fratrie une femme qui va servir en fait
aussi bien
sexuellement que dans l'espace
domestique à tous les hommes de la
famille voilà et la politique de
l'enfant unique en Chine a été elle a
aussi dévastatrice et peut-être même
d'une certaine manière je sais pas dans
l'horreur si on peut hiérarchiser mais
peut-être pire parce que là en fait on
tuait des filles à la naissance je vous
écoute et c'est un peu de décourageant
en fait quand on voit toute cette
violence qui existe encore aujourd'hui
comment on fait pour éradiquer cette
cette violence je ne sais pas moi je
n'ai pas de je n'ai pas de solution un
miracle moi mon travail c'est de c'est
d'éclairer les phénomènes de produire un
outil de savoir académique militants
journalistique artistique de mettre en
avant les témoignages des survivants il
y a des solutions il y a bien sûr
l'outil formidable des sororités entre
femmes moi j'y crois beaucoup ce livre
incarne une immense sororité à l'échelle
du monde et montre que on peut
travailler dans le respect la
bienveillance la solidarité
et la non-violence qui sont des valeurs
qui sont des valeurs à l'opposé de celle
de la masculinité gémonique et la seule
manière de s'en sortir en fait c'est de
c'est de tourner le dos au projet
politique du patriarcat et dans
construire un nouveau
à égalité entre hommes et femmes les
femmes prennent leur part les hommes
doivent prendre la leur
tout un programme absolument merci
beaucoup madame c'est moi qui vous
remercie de votre invitation